november the 2nd 1948 out came the voters in
town and city and they came in record numbers
50 million of them as one editorial put it
the election must be held for no other reason
to find out which national pollster came closest
the experts had told the people what they were
thinking the candidates had told them what they
ought to think but now the people were saying what
they really thought in the only way that counted
the suspense wasn't exactly feverish when first
returns were broadcast out in h.b is leading in
11 states having a total of 93 electoral votes
only one percent of colorado is reporting and
jewie is ahead well there seems to be a trend and
the trend is for dewey 80 of connecticut is now in
dewey is ahead dewey 406 000 truman 399 000 well
that's again again for dewey all the gains that
i have figured out so far are on dewey's
side with the exception of west virginia
it all seemed to be going according to
oil but as the returns kept piling up
something unbelievable began to happen and
it wasn't according to gallop roper or hoyle
harry took the lead all right and he never
looked back and what were the pundits saying now
the democratic sweep continues and it not only
confounds the experts it literally confounds
history president truman undoubtedly
has strung the greatest political upset
the greatest personal political
upset of our modern times
at the electoral college dinner
in january the star performer was
who else harry s truman president on his
own it was quite a performance wake up
but the president was breaking his weekend
saying a hurried goodbye to his wife and
taking off suddenly for washington it was a major
crisis crisis in a distant place called korea
and it brought the president winging back to
washington on that sunday afternoon in june
the communists of north korea launched an
unprovoked invasion of the free republic
of south korea the president and the
country faced a historic decision
secretary of state dean atchison was at the
airport for immediate consultation with the
president an emergency conference with
the secretary of defense and the joint
chiefs of staff had been called in korea
the situation was worsening by the hour